افادت وكاله بلومبرج عن مصادر مطلعه عن
الاداره الامريكيه تدرس رساله مركبات
برادلي القتاليه الى اوكرانيا كجزء من
حزمه اخرى من الدعم العسكري
بعد بشان ارسال المركبات كما ان موعده
تشغيلها غير واضحه ايضا
اخر الاخبار على الارض وهل من تفاعل مع
التصريحات القادمه من نيته
نعم سفيان اسمح لي ان ابدا من تطورات
سياسيه الرئيس الاوكراني خلال الساعات
الماضيه قال بان كل هجوم صاروخي يقترب او
يستهدف العاصمه كياب والمقاطعات الاخرى
شمالا وجنوبا من شان ان يقرب موسكو من
المحاكمه محكمه دوليه نتيجه الجرائم التي
تقوم بها على حد وصف قبل ذلك كان مستشار
رئيس الاوكراني ايضا يتحدث الى احدى
القنوات المحليه هنا في العاصمه كيف يقول
بان هنالك توافق كامل بين اكياب واشنطن
على مختلف القضايا المتعلقه بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الى درجه تصل الى
100% على حد وصفه وقال بان الولايات
المتحده تعلم جيدا كيف يتوجب ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب وما هي اهداف كياف منها وما هي
التنازلات التي لا يجب التراجع عنها او
تقديمها في اي محادثات محتمله في المستقبل
بين كياب وموسكوس وان كانت محادثات مباشره
او غير مباشره قال بانه لن يكون هنالك
مينسك 2 في اشاره الى محادثات
والاتفاقيات التي كان من الممكن ان تمضي
قبل الحرب في العاصمه بلا روسيه تحديدا
فيما يخص اعطاء وضع خاص من قبل كيرف لا
اقليم جمباز وهمم يعني همم قال واكد بانه
لن يعني يتم العوده الى المربع الاول في
العاصمه همم بلا روسيه وقال بان الثوابت
الاوكرانيه جدد على الثوابت الاوكرانيه
التي يتم الحديث هنا عنها من المسؤولين
السياسيين قال بانه لن يتم التنازل عن اي
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه في المستقبل في حال
تم الجلوس على طاوله الحوار بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرد انه يتوجب العوده الى
حدود و90 في ما يتعلق همم الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اقليم الدومباس يجب ان يكون
اوكرانيا بالكامل ويجب ان يكون هنالك
اقرار من الطرف الروسي بذلك بالاضافه الى
استعاده شبه جزيره القرم وقال بان اي نصر
تحققه القوات الاوكرانيه او سياسيا
دبلوماسيه لكيف في هذه الحرب هو انتصار
على حد وصفه للولايات المتحده همم
الامريكيه قبل ذلك ايضا خرج ميخائيل
بدلالك مستشار المستشار في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه وقال بان همم روسيا غير جاده
في اي حوار في اي حديث عن محادثات
ومباحثات وقال بان الحل الوحيد في هذه
الاثناء هو التسريع في اا يعني تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه لتحقيق ما وصفه همم
بالنصر على صعيد الجبهات ميدانيا التطورات
متسارعه الاساسيه في جنوب البلاد نهايه
سفيان خلال دقائق الاخيره تحدثت الاداره
العسكريه بيرسون عن قصف المدينه بالمدفعيه
وبقدائف الهاون اكثر من 80 مره خلال
الساعات الماضيه وانا انتظر هذا الهواء
اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في عموم جنوب
اوكرانيا وفقا لسلطات العسكريه هناك وفي
الشرق نهايه تقول هل السلطات بانها تواصل
صد هجوم للقوات الروسيه على اكثر من جبهه
على اكثر من محور تحديدا في دنيا سكولوجان
باتجاه باخموت التي ما زالت تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه